هل هناك ضوء في نهاية
النفق في العلاقة المظلمة في
الوقت الحالي بين الكاتا والسعوديين
والإماراتيين ، سنظل نأمل أن يكون
هناك فتح سابق في
الشهرين الماضيين لحوار بين
قطر والسعودية للأسف لم يحدث ذلك '
نتج عن ذلك تعليق القنوات
ولكن قطر كانت دائمًا واضحة جدًا في
أننا منفتحون على الحوار ، فنحن
منفتحون على المشاركة طالما أنها
تحترم القانون الدولي
وسيادة كل دولة نريدها
نريد الأفضل لنا جميعًا.  جميع
جيراننا في المنطقة نريد
أن نتطلع إلى المستقبل ونتطلع إلى
مستقبل أكثر ازدهارًا واستقرارًا في
تلك المنطقة ، ولا يمكن أن يحدث
هذا من خلال نهج لعبة محصلتها صفر ، لا يمكن أن يحدث إلا من
خلال المساومة من قبل جميع
الأطراف والوصول إلى
تسوية أصبحنا جميعًا مالكين لم
نقصد أبدًا تقويضها أو إهانتها
لأي بلد نريده نريدهم أن
يخرجوا من هذا أقوى
ونظهر جميعًا  أقوى إقليميًا
وأعتقد أن هذه ستكون فرصة تاريخية
لنا لنكون أكثر
استشرافية كيف نريد مستقبلنا
مثلها وكيف يمكننا
الحماية من أي صراع مستقبلي
مثل دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
[موسيقى]